you said this term a couple of times
today
picking the woman that picks you yeah
what does that mean specifically and
what is it how do you know when a woman
has picked you is this an explicit hey I
like your Vibe I want to be with you
because
I haven't had many I end up in exclusive
relationships but I don't typically have
the exclusive relationship conversation
like it just kind of gets to that point
somehow so I'm wondering if
I'm either not picking a woman that
picks me or I'm just kind of falling
into a bit what what is the the what are
the signs I guess when a woman has
picked you it should be like taking a
frying pan to the forehead it should be
pretty obvious right I mean like a woman
that's chosen you
um she'll take the initiative to do
things in your life you know to you know
to improve it she'll when you get up in
the morning she'll make the bed for you
uh if she sees a pile of laundry around
she'll put it in the machine and start
doing it for you you know she'll she'll
clean up your house uh hey I'm coming
over in about an hour and a half Robert
uh be naked when I get there and is
there a wine that you want me to bring
over you know sort of thing um it's
usually pretty obvious like like guys
will know when a woman uh chooses them
right look it's pretty clear
yeah okay and then I usually end up
dating like these kind of type a women
um which I they women what is that I
want to say type A they're like very end
oh type A yeah sorry type A as opposed
to type B so very independent then
usually very ambitious and whatever
they're doing their their job or
whatever their activity is
um
usually very responsible like almost
hyper responsible yeah these are
actually things I appreciate because I'm
that way too I'm very independent like I
go and do my thing I don't need a lot of
emotional support or hand-holding
through life I like to just do my own
thing and so it seems like it's worked
out where I've dated a woman that does
something similar and then when we come
back together at night like it's all
good but when you just now described
what it's like when they pick you like I
don't know that I've
seen those signs in them as much because
they're usually about their their
business or whatever their thing is
um
is there another way to approach that
like how it you obviously can't ask a
woman like hey did you pick me
uh
if it's obvious as a frying pan to the
forehead I guess is there are there more
subtle indications for women that might
not be doing or other things no genuine
burning desire looks like that but I
mean if you're also dating boss girls
which is basically what you're
describing they're generally not the
type that are that feminine they're more
masculine you know because they've been
told that chase degrees climb the
corporate ladder bring those degrees of
mahogany you know they have to have
little letters after the name you know
signifying the importance so
um that's they they have essentially
been told to behave and become like men
and let me ask you a question do you
find do you find these women exhausting
sometimes you know these boss girls
well I find all women exhausting
sometimes
um what would be my
if anything like
and I have dated the opposite right the
one that are very dependent
irresponsible you know want to be with
you all the time and like that really
doesn't work for me because I'm very
independent like a lot of solitude Etc
yes dated the opposite that's worse but
the complaint I would have about the
type A
is that they might be just a little
too
um you know sometimes I'm like oh we've
got some time together let's spin
they're like no I got to go do the thing
and run errands or whatever and it's
like okay well let's kind of comes with
the territory but when you say
exhausting do you mean like her
personalities wearing me out or what is
this
what do you mean um
well you know behaving in a masculine
sort of way like uh you know give an
example like the uh realtor is a good
example of the type A Boss uh girl sort
of uh date I was out on a date once and
we met for sushi and you know how
realtors are I mean if their client
calls they usually jump and when the
class says uh something you know she's
responding with well how high should I
jump
um so I'm on a date with her she's very
attractive having a great conversation
boss girl you know powersu drives a nice
BMW sort of SUV uh gets a phone call or
a text and she looks and she goes I've
got to go I've got to show a house I've
got this client that is probably gonna
buy it and then myself well that's
interesting
so we're sitting here we're eating we're
on a date but you're gonna bounce
because you want to go and do this
whatever and then you know she said to
me well you should come along for the
ride you know sort of thing like it'd
only be a few minutes because you have
to show the house right it's just uh you
know five or ten minutes away
um that's the sort of thing that you
tend to get with like these boss girls
right is like they will
I mean they will make their career their
job the absolute priority and it's not
you that matters and if you want a
family if you want a girlfriend even
um you want a woman that's a compliment
to your life that you know that would
say to you well you know Robert what
what can I do to make myself useful
today you know like I know that you're
out there chasing Excellence you're
doing your thing you're building your
audience doing whatever
um how how can I help
um and to me I mean a little bit older
than you but to me that's a lot more
attractive than the girl that's got the
degrees like my ex-wife's a lawyer right
so I've I've dated lots of Boss girls
accountants uh entrepreneurs all that
stuff and after a while I think once
you've dated enough of them and yeah
they're successful and they got a cool
house too and they drive a nice car as
well and you know they've got money to
you know take care of things they don't
usually beg you for anything or any of
that stuff
um but the whole you know rah-rah raw
sort of stuff gets a little bit tiring
um it's only okay I find when they can
submit when they're in your frame frame
like when you're with them right so in
the bedroom you know for example they
completely you know submit to like
they're not a boss in that type of
situation when you know when you're
making plans for something like uh hey
you know let's go out and get something
to eat it's not you sitting there going
well where do you want to go I don't
know where do you want to go and you're
kind of sitting there you know it's like
no put on the black dress that I like
I'm taking you over to the sushi place
and we're going in five minutes yeah
sort of thing like it's okay when she
complies you know to my frame but I find
that a lot of them they have some
difficulty with that it's you know they
have a mindset of oh well I got this or
I can take care of things or I don't
need you sort of thing I think at the
end of the day one of the problems with
you know they're fine with a lot of
these boss girls is they've got really
high Notch counts right they don't they
don't preserve their value and because
they tend to adopt masculine traits and
Chase excellence and climb the corporate
ladder and all this stuff they tend to
act a lot like men so they're very
promiscuous and a woman that's had laid
with a lot of men in her past isn't
doesn't make a great girlfriend you know
because usually what ends up happening
is if something doesn't go her way or or
it's not working out she's not very
sticky in the relationship it's like you
know if she's already been with 51 guys
and you're number 52 she doesn't care
she'll she'll just move on into number
53. she's already done it 51 times right
so she's not she's not that committed to
the relationship or you
um so type A is like
I found a place in my 20s and my 30s
where I was sold this narrative like you
know men and women are equal and will be
the twin towers together we'll you know
challenge life you know together go
forth and be a a force of Awesomeness
you know sort of thing but I think you
find after a while if you dated you know
somebody like that or even been married
to them it's pretty exhausting and they
usually end up at some point trying to
run your life
yeah and I've
seen the relationship usually ends up if
there is a power
boss girl I guess as you would say that
she ends up with a not a boss guy like
the guy kind of feels a a baby at least
she has to settle for that guy because
there's a lot of this going on with
um you know the boss girls and
interestingly there's a really good book
uh called the birth order book I think
Dr Kevin Lehman is the author's name and
he breaks down the personality types and
archetypes of firstborn second third
born sort of thing and like the vast
majority of these boss girls out there
they're almost always a firstborn right
because they had to lead the you know
the siblings in the family they were
always the ones you know testing the
parents the parents were testing their
skills on on them
um so it's not that you know it's not
like they're bad people or anything like
that it's just generally speaking unless
she can submit to your frame and if
you're a leader yeah um then you're
probably going to have some difficulty
dealing with her on a long-term basis it
gets it's just not fun you know if I can
put it that way yeah yeah no that makes
sense I I heard recently that one of the
greatest gifts uh masculine energy
or a man can give a woman or feminine
energy
is the ability to just turn off her
brain
so like the man can step in be the
leader you know like you said put on the
black dress or go to the sushi place I'm
like women actually long for that yeah
and so that was interesting because as a
man we process information differently
you're like oh well like should we look
at the options together and think about
this yeah yeah it's it you know it's
interesting because when you enter a
strong masculine frame you know yourself
you start to behave a lot differently
like I even noticed myself a few years
ago uh like if I'd be walking down the
street my girlfriend you know you're
holding hands you're sort of doing your
thing I sometimes found myself with her
on the outside of the sidewalk and me on
the inside and I inherently know that
you know if if I'm gonna lead in this
relationship and she's going to follow
it and happily you know want to want to
do that I need to protect her like I
need to be able to do that so I have to
stand on the app so I'll just move her
over and I'll switch sides and she knows
exactly what I'm doing and she likes
that right like yeah you know
um there's always a lot of pushback when
you have these conversations you know
these traditional sort of like uh
relation ship sort of
mechanisms that make them work better
but the truth of the matter is they work
better you know I'm in a great
relationship I mean I'm a little bit
older I'm a seasoned gentleman you know
I've been married divorced I've had lots
of long-term relationships dated all
that good stuff
um
I wish I could have figured this out in
my 20s like life would have been a lot
better I wouldn't have made some stupid
mistakes for sure yeah yeah I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out
all right good morning welcome to the
89th installment of the play and win
podcast series uh Tony Hughes joins me
today what is up my friend whoa Rich
Cooper In the Flesh there well good to
see uh good to talk to you on a podcast
for the first time yeah yeah man
um I've seen quite a few of your videos
over the past past few years uh love the
conversations that you've had you're
clearly very knowledgeable on the topics
that you discussed which is usually
around
bodybuilding biohacking peptides
performance enhancing drugs all that
good stuff you live in Thailand
so what time is it over there it's got
to be late at night 9 p.m 9 p.m cool so
uh